Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Jessica Jones episode 9 through 12
video. Everything from Beginning of Sin Bin
through Jessica Jones vs Luke Cage, so here
we go! Just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen through Jessica Jones on episode 12 yet
but one of my favorite episodes was number
nine because we learned so much about Killgrave
we learned that he was abused as a child and
essentially left to fend on his own like they
just let them artistry his parents took off
they were so afraid to be fair to his mother
she had that giant burn from the iron on her
face to show exactly what had happened but
you know he says why didn't know what was
going on I was a little child so if he's psychopath
that has zero empathy for everyone else like
he has no idea what everyone else is feeling
because he's never able to tell whether or
not people are doing what he asked because
they want to or because of his powers he did
make it seem like as an adult he could choose
to not use his powers on people but just just
to use some Doctor who logic the doctor lies
I'm guessing that it's a passive ability that
he doesn't really have control over it just
it's always on the way his father explains
it like that the origin of Killgrave so to
speak is that he had a degenerative brain
condition they introduced a very special experimental
virus and even though that fixed in the side
effect was is that he started to admit this
virus the just caused everyone to listen to
whatever suggestions he gave them but here's
the deal because eventually he tries to amp
his powers up there is a degree of proximity
involved and it's not psychic he actually
has to speak the words which is why they use
the headphones in later episodes so think
of him as being like a bio computer hacker
like if you were to walk by am in a crowd
there's nothing you could do to stop him from
uploading the virus to you but as long as
you can't hear what he says he cannot input
commands so you're you're still okay to go
so it's not so much the virus need to worry
about its him giving you commands why you're
affected by the virus and I know a lot of
people think that that person by the club
is stuck forever staring at that fence because
he did tell him that when his powers were
enhanced as long as it wore off within like
a week or so he probably would not die from
dehydration you can go without food a lot
longer that you can go without water but he's
probably okay the pry survived isn't it crazy
the like all throughout the series even in
the earlier episodes how Jessica runs in the
people who are able to fulfill their commands
so they just go crazy like Patsy trying to
put the bullet in her head so Jessica has
to like literally put the bullet in her mouth
see it's in your head you can stop now you
guys can let me know if you agree or not though
do you feel like the last couple of episodes
start to get more and more graphic like the
stuff the Killgrave does the way he kills
his father in the way he dealt with the other
two dues that he stole the apartment from
1000 cuts to Jeryn Hogarth did feel like it
was justified like she definitely got what
she deserved that whole storyline felt a little
contrived like it was only there to give him
a way to get out they set her up to be like
okay I'm in a turn this off and release them
then it all goes sideways Killgrave ends up
killing his mother was is also one of the
more graphic killings stab yourself for every
year that you left me alone Killgrave getting
out will Simpson burning down all the evidence
it all feels like the story just trying to
give Jessica more reasons to have to kill
Killgrave like they won't have the evidence
against them because it all got burned down
so they can't prosecute them and kill great
power start to go off the scale so he's able
to my control people at great distances I
know everybody's asking about IGH an officer
Simpson because he is definitely nuke from
the comics he's kind like an early proto-version
of the punisher but because we have the punisher
in the Netflix universe on I'm not gonna calm
the punisher he is one of the few actors that
I did not like an Jessica Jones I feel like
his performance was just completely would
he worked way better in the early episodes
when he was just the sex buddy just the person
for Patsy to say hey you know last night was
fun but shut up don't talk the reason their
seating this IGH stuff like you know connecting
all these enhanced people to this IGH company
the pills Jessica Jones Killgrave the reason
I could try to connect this is because they're
trying to create more mythology that they
can dig into in season two like officer Simpson
says he's re-upping with his old group and
it and it looks like this Hydra type organization
they're very organized organa do good things
together son they answered zero questions
about that so that's all season two stuff
just just considered off in the distance but
the Simpson character or new character you
want to think of him is a villain from the
daredevil comics but he also crosses over
with a lot of Capt. America comics to think
of him is a more sinister version of the punisher
he wants to do good he wears the flag but
he just goes completely over party just out-of-control
the organization in the comics that nuke is
tied to is called the weapon plus program
you think remorse and for that is like the
US government responding to the potential
threat of a mutant human war so tries to create
its own super soldiers will Simpson is just
part of that the characterization kind of
comes through in that the Jessica Jones version
of the character like he's trying to kill
Killgrave because he's like we can't prosecute
them he's too dangerous be just so over-the-top
nuts that he completely kills everyone else
because he thinks they're going to stop him
from killing Killgrave Salcedo like many the
storylines that I didn't really like during
Jessica Jones I'd I didn't like the will Simpson
stuff I do feel like they just needed like
a version of Killgrave for Patsy to overcome
and that was that she the fun part when she
takes the pills will start that that's what
they were headed the minute she took the pills
from well the first time she ran afoul of
them after he came back on the pills like
she took some stick them in her pocket like
oh yeah she's definitely get to take those
she almost dies they bring her back and she
just like hell yeah that was so amazing is
this what you feel like all the time Jessica
to just expect more crazy Patsy stuff like
that in season two she was a lot of fun I
love the Patsy character I'm so glad that
it was her and not Carol Danvers Capt. Marvel
very awesome character in the marvel universe
but a I think she'll work just a lot better
in the movies that she would in the TV show
like this that we got to talk about Luke Cage
under Killgrave's control it was so fun watching
him will rush him and kill great just had
to like put his hand up what you want with
me want to kill you take a blood he number
we also learn the Jessica is able to severely
injure Luke with a shotgun blast to the head
now he has superstrong skin but his internal
organs are not superstrong they're just normal
internal organs so if they needed to operate
on his internal organs they could also go
in through his mouth of they had to but know
this Netflix version of Luke Cage is completely
normal underneath his skin is just as the
skin is just as hard layer severe wanted to
take them down you don't use batches had really
hard against the curb if you never read world
war hold whatever hole comes back from planet
Hulk does want to destroy every hero in the
marvel universe in order to take Wolverine
down because Wolverine has a healing factor
the only way whole can stop them is bike bashing
his head so hard that it turns his brain into
mush so Wolverine is incapacitated while his
brain regenerates but if you felt like the
episode started to drag towards the middle
of the run if you like his last couple of
episodes is where the energy gets cranked
up in between episodes nine and 12 I'll say
episode nine is priced though my favorite
number to do a separate video for episode
13 but if you guys want you can ask the questions
about that to like the way it in season two
stuff I'm in a do in episode 13 video and
then I'll do a season two predictions video
like you for storylines that I think they
should do or characters I think they should
bring in the let me know in the comments what
was your favorite thing from his last block
of episodes and in what you think is going
on with this IGH group do you think they're
connected to Hydra or do you think of their
own separate thing my thoughts with the IGH
because they they don't really tied to a specific
comic book group is that they're going to
be this separate entity that they might be
a loosely click to Hydra but they probably
won't there was this line in a recent agent
to shield episode if you haven't been watching
it where they say Hydra is a very complex
organization in the ideas that Hydra is a
secret organization that has its own secret
organizations inside of it that Hydra members
don't know about so IGH could be one of those
but if like everyone in 10 person in a place
of authority is connected to Hydra then IGH
probably has some loose ties to it and just
to clarify they haven't take Jessica Jones
up for season two officially yet but I would
expect an announcement within the next couple
of weeks usually usually they wait just a
little while in case you guys haven't seen
it I posted a Batman view Superman video you
can click here to watch that learn all about
the next season coming and you can click here
for the Captain America Civil War trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody,
let's high five and I'll see you tonight!